es brodelt in der spd denn selten lagen
machen das eigentlich die grünen und die
diese schweren waffen lieferungen
ministerpräsidentin von schleswig
altkanzler gesprochen ich wollte mich
fdp noch weiter mit also wir sind da
zugesagt dementsprechend hat olaf scholz
holstein könnte die liste beliebig
führende sozialdemokraten so daneben wie
erkundigen was das ergebnis seiner
fortsetzen und deswegen glaube ich muss
ganz klar an der stelle und ich werde
da gelogen was hat er damit gemeint mit
beim umgang mit wladimir putin im fokus
gespräche geführt mit der ukraine
auch dafür plädieren dass wir nächste
man das schon ein wenig auseinander
er will keine alleingänge obwohl er gar
woche einen antrag in den bundestag
der kritik ist natürlich auch ex kanzler
sagt der hamburger cdu politiker
nicht allein wäre
einbringen der den kanzler hier zum
gerhard schröder ein besonders enger
siemens richtig angesprochen ich
christoph de vries dankeschön dass er
handeln auffordert ihre kritik an der
putin freund der sich bis heute nicht
das war der wunsch dass das mal wissen
verfolgte er regelmäßig ihren ticker und
sich die zeit genommen haben
alleine gestern haben die usa kanada
vom despoten distanziert hat ja aber
wer und wie sind sie auf ihn zugegangen
spd ist deutlich man muss allerdings
auch sigmar gabriel steht in der kritik
belgien niederlande die lieferung
oder hat er sie an anna ich habe ihn
auch sagen viele jahre war die
nachdem er ja frank walter steinmeier
gefragt ob wenn wir das erzählen
schwerer waffen angekündigt das heißt
bundeskanzlerin eine cdu-frau an der
gegen kritik des botschafters melnik mit
hier von einem alleingang zu sprechen
hatten wir darüber berichtet
dem wort bösartig verteidigte nun vor
macht sie hat auch ein sehr enges
ist ja eine schutzbehauptung aber es
verhältnis zu russland sogar die mir
noch mal zurückkommen zum thema spd denn
wenigen stunden haben sich ausgerechnet
passt in das muster der ständigen
putin gepflegt das heißt die cdu kann
schröder und gabriel getroffen das ist
ausflüchte die wir seit wochen und
sich dadurch auch nicht aus der
die kritik die reist ja nicht ab sie
verantwortung stehlen was würden sie
schon eine echte überraschung um genau 9
diesen bundeskanzler leider erleben und
kommt unter anderem auch aus der
denn jetzt anders machen
hamburger cdu von politiker christoph de
05 kam sigmar gabriel bei schröder in
das ist zum nachteil der ukraine um ihre
ich will vielleicht auch den ersten teil
hannover an wurde vom ex kanzler b
vries schönen guten tag schön dass sie
der frage mal eingehen jeder der regiert
existenz kämpft das ist aber auch zum
bei uns sind holen
sehens an der pforte begrüßt und dann
nachteil des ansehens deutschlands in
hat in den letzten jahrzehnten da muss
sind beide rein um 10.40 also nach gut
sie haben die spd wirklich hart
sich dieser verantwortung stellen und
der welt das muss man an dieser stelle
kritisiert haben da sogar von dem spd
der muss sie auch tragen und da können
einer stunde verließ gabriel das haus
einfach ganz klar sagen müssen ich bin
sumpf gesprochen was wären denn jetzt
dann wieder schröders ehefrau so jan
wir uns auch nicht entziehen wo wir den
heute bei einem arzt gewesen der hat
letzten 16 jahren regiert haben aber ich
schröder kim die hat dann noch ein
die konsequenzen die die
mich gespritzt und der hat gefragt wann
sozialdemokraten ziehen müssten gibt es
schickes abschiedsfoto von den beiden
glaube dass alleine zu sagen wäre zu
handelt ihr endlich wann hilft endlich
da jetzt rücktrittsforderungen
gemacht
ihrerseits
einfach die spd hat in den letzten 22
darüber müsse man natürlich sprechen mit
die bundesrepublik deutschland der
ich glaube es wird in diesen tagen klar
jahren 18 jahre regiert sie hat dort in
bild meinung chefin pia torf er ist uns
ukraine umfassend mit militärischer
dass die spd eine historische schuld auf
der regel immer den wirtschaftsminister
live aus dem ukrainischen den nico
hilfe mit schweren waffen tretet diesen
den außenminister gestellt als
zugeschaltet philipp sigmar gabriel
sich geladen hat und die frage ist wie
bundeskanzler doch mal gehörig in denen
zweitgrößte kraft bis auch die letzten
trifft gerd schröder das hat uns jeden
geht sie mit dieser historischen schuld
und weiter sache ist auch nicht und ich
vier jahre
berlin schon ziemlich überrascht was
um sie könnte einen klaren schlussstrich
insofern war sie immer dabei und es gibt
glaubst du steckt dahinter
sehe es ganz genauso und man spürt dass
ziehen unter die mitgliedschaft von
auch diese stimmung der verdruss ist
ja da treffen sich zwei ehemalige
zwei unterschiedliche dinge wir müssen
groß unter unmut es muss jetzt wirklich
gerhard schröder frau
uns den vorwurf gefallen lassen dass wir
deutsche politiker die sehr viel dafür
darum gehen wladimir putin diesen
ministerpräsidentin schließlich könnt
im hinblick auf die energiepolitik nicht
getan haben dass deutschland ein viel zu
ihren rücktritt erklären olaf scholz
brutalen skrupellosen kriegstreiber mit
wachsam genug gewesen sind und uns da zu
könnte als bundeskanzler endlich den
gutes verhältnis zu russland hatte und
allen verfügbaren mitteln unterhalb
hebel umlegen und du keine hilfe leisten
abhängig gemacht haben und in
diesen kriegsverbrecher putin zu lange
eines kriegseintritt zu stoppen und da
deutschland auch zu kurzfristigen
vierter zu lange komplett unterschätzt
mit schweren waffen bisher hat die spd
ist noch eine menge luft nach oben das
stimmungen gefolgt sind wenn ich denke
glaube ich glaube wir sind der
hat bei ex kanzler schröder muss man
alle chancen vertan in dieser hinsicht
cdu-politiker und gehören
an den atomausstieg und wenn ich auch
dementsprechend zur größten
sagen das ist mittlerweile seit jahren
ich verstehe sie richtig sie fordern
oppositionspartei an aber aus ihrer
denke an den kohleausstieg werden diese
ein angestellter putins eine einer
auch den rücktritt von manuela schwesig
partei hört man sonst auch eher wenig
seiner wichtigsten lobbyisten und bei
schritte nicht gegangen worden hätten
wenn sich das bewahrheitet was ihre
wir diese abhängigkeit vom russischen
zum beispiel friedrich merz hat sich
sigmar gabriel ist dass offenbar jemand
bisher noch kaum geäußert eher
gas worte nicht und damit müssen wir uns
kolleginnen und kollegen recherchiert
der versucht noch irgendwie großer mühe
zurückgehalten warum ist das so
als union auch kritisch
haben dass gazprom unmittelbar die feder
auseinandersetzen eine ganz andere
auf die richtige seite der geschichte zu
also das nehme ich an dass friedrich
geschwungen hat bei den verträgen bei
rutschen aber es ist einfach zu spät
qualität hat aber das handeln der spd
merz heute morgen in einem langen
der gründung der stiftung dann kann
jetzt fragt man sich natürlich was die
interview gehört wo er ganz klar kritik
dort wo wir einmal eine große naivität
beiden bei diesen treffen besprochen
manuela schwesig nicht länger im amt
geäußert hat die forderung nach schweren
erleben aber dann auch eine sehr sehr
haben danach wird es vielleicht heißen
seien eine deutsche ministerpräsidentin
starke persönliche politische nähe
dass man natürlich ein hartes offenes
wochen lieferungen auch klar formuliert
die sich direkt regieren lässt aus dem
hat das haben viele kolleginnen und
gespräch geführt hat das wird vielleicht
führender spitzenpolitiker seit
kreml die ist aus meiner sicht nicht
kollegen auch gestern gemacht so war
sigmar gabriel sagen aber das sieht man
jahrzehnten die direkten persönlichen
haltbar klare worte hier wir haben ja
davor oder recht kiesewetter wir sind da
glaube ich allein an der freundlichkeit
kontakt zu putin zulauf hatten die
dieser bilder nicht da treffen sich zwei
ganz klar aufgestellt vielleicht ist
gerade auch schon darüber gesprochen
dass eben der kanzler davon spricht dass
manchmal das interesse an den
unkritische des handelns kommentiert
die sich sehr gut verstehen und die
gegenstimmen der regierungsfraktionen im
er eben keine schweren waffen an die
haben ihr kollege petrow hat das ja hier
ukraine mehr liefern möchte um vor allem
ungeachtet aller kritik zueinander
moment auch etwas höher wenn ich dann
direkt vorher auch benannt wäre dort
halten philipp werden die möglichkeit
toni hofreiter denke produkte stark
alleingänge zu vermeiden neben holland
alles beteiligt ist sigmar gabriel der
auch mit sigmar gabriel kurz zu sprechen
belgien kanada und die usa haben aber
zimmermann wir sehen ja auch das ist ein
wir wollen einmal reinhören was er genau
zerwürfnis hier gibt innerhalb der
heutige bundespräsident
auch mehrere andere länder auch noch
im anschluss an dieses gespräch gesagt
regierung und die spannende frage ist
erwin sellering hat klar die
hat was haben sie denn hannover mit dem
natürlich auch diese stellt wie lange